what i want to do in this video is get
some practice visualizing what happens
if we were to try to rotate
two-dimensional shapes in three
dimensions what do i mean by that let's
say i started with a right triangle
so let's say
my right triangle looks like this
so let's say it looks like
that
right over there
and so this is a right angle and let's
say that this
this this width right over here is three
units and let's say that this length is
five units
and i'm going to do something
interesting i'm going to take this two
dimensional right triangle and i'm going
to try to rotate it in three dimensions
around this line around
the line that i'm doing as a dotted
magenta line so i'm going to rotate it
around this line right over there so if
i were to rotate it around this line
what type of a shape am i going to get
and i encourage you once again it's
going to be a three-dimensional shape i
encourage you to think about it maybe
take out a piece of paper draw it or
just try to imagine it in your head
well let's to think about in three
dimensions what i'm going to do is try
to look at this thing in three
dimensions so let me draw this same line
but i'm going to draw it in an angle so
we can visualize the whole thing in
three dimensions
so imagine if this was sitting on the
ground
so that's our magenta line
and then i can draw my triangle so my
triangle would look something like this
so it would look like it would look like
this
so once again this is 5 units this is 3
units this is a right triangle
i'm going to rotate it around the line
so what's it going to look like
well this this end right over here is
going to rotate around and it's going to
form a circle with a radius of 3.
right so it's going to form so when it
intersects if that was on the ground
it's going to be 3 again and let me draw
it down so it's going to keep going down
whoops
i don't want to
press the wrong button so it's going to
look something like this that's what the
base is going to look like
but then this end right over here is
going to stay at a point because this is
right on that magenta line so it's just
going to stay at a point and so if you
were to look at the intersect so it
would look something like this so it'd
look like this and then
you'd have another thing that goes like
this and so if you were to take a
section like this it would you would
have a little smaller circle here based
on what this distance is
so what is the shape
what is the shape that i am drawing
well what you see what it is it's it's a
cone it's a cone and if i shade it in
you might see the cone a little bit
better so let me
shade it in so you see
you see the cone
so what you end up getting
is a cone
where it's base so i'm shading it in
so that hopefully helps a little bit
so what you end up getting is a cone
where the base has a radius of three
units
so let me draw this so this right over
here is the radius of the base
and it is three units i could also draw
it like this
so the cone is going to look like this
and this is the tip of the cone
and it's going to look
just like
just like this and once again let me
shade it a little bit so that you can
appreciate
that this is a three-dimensional shape
so
draw the cone so you can shade it
and we can even construct the original
so that
well or we can construct this original
shape so you see how it constructs so it
makes this the line that magenta line is
going to do this type of thing
it's going to go through the center of
the base
it's going to go through the center of
the base
just like that
and our original shape our original
right triangle
if you just took a cross section of it
that included
that included that line you would have
your original shape i'm just in orange
so the original shape is right
is right over there so what do you get
you get a cone where the radius of the
base is three units
interesting